hey this is presh tallwalker and you're
watching mind your decisions
consider a rectangular array of circles
we'll fill in some of these circles to
make a mathematical expression it
currently reads the quantity 10 plus 11
times the quantity 10 minus 11 is equal
to 100 plus
1 factorial
but this is not currently a valid
equation
the challenge is to color four blue dots
or erase four blue dots to make a valid
equation
i think professor pierre johansson at
forzheim university for creating this
puzzle
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you are
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we make this into a valid
equation
the amazing answer is that we're going
to make each 11 into a 1 times i
we need to erase a total of four dots
in each of the elevens we're going to
erase two dots
for example in the first 11 we erase
this dot and then this dot
and in the second 11 we do the same
thing
so now the left hand side becomes the
quantity 10 plus 1 times i
times the quantity 10 minus 1 times i
when we expand this out we get 100 plus
10i minus 10i minus i squared
this simplifies to be 100 minus i
squared
which is equal to 100 minus
a negative 1
which then becomes 101 which is exactly
equal to 100 plus 1 factorial
the solution is complex but the answer
is quite real did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free inspire and build confidence for
people around the world and they already
have over a hundred million views
let's share the beauty of mathematics
with your help we can math the world a
better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos email me a
puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support